water is the basis of life and only a
tiny share of all the water on Earth is
fresh and renewed by the water cycle if
you took all the water in the world and
put it into a gallon jug less than one
teaspoon of it would be available to us
we're overusing it we're over tapping
rivers and we're over pumping
groundwater we live at a time in history
where over a billion people don't have
access to safe drinking water and over
three billion people have no access to
sanitation
water is a global issue but it's also a
very local issue we forget that we live
on hydrosphere and that all of our water
resources are connected water that runs
in the Ganges could also end up in the
Hudson or could fall over the plains of
Africa or could make a cup of tea in the
Queen's palace
to support the average American
lifestyle today takes about twice the
global average the great American lawn
is a great example of one of the myriad
of ways that we take water for granted
we can't continue to flaunt our water
agriculture is something that we really
need to give thought to 70% of all the
water we extract from rivers lakes and
aquifers goes to irrigated agriculture
to some extent we're using some of
tomorrow's water to meet today's food
demands large number people I talked to
when they learn that the Colorado the
mighty force of nature no longer reaches
the sea there's a look of shock in most
people's faces at the Delta literally
runs dry we are using and abusing our
water resources in ways that are
completely unsustainable and unless we
think about it that way and we start
taking action at an individual level
then I don't really see how we'll be
able to overcome so many of the issues
that we're going to be faced with in the
next 50 years and this is our time in
history to do something about it
you